[Music]
an initial toxicology report from
Matthew Perry's autopsy indicates a lack
of two specific drugs in the lat ACTA
system following his tragic death at age
54 on October 28th but that's not the
end of the story police told TMZ that
Perry did not have either fentel or meth
two common culprits in opioid relate to
deaths in his system at the time of his
passing additional testing will take 4
to 6 months to complete further
toxicology testing will investigate
whether Perry had other substances in
his system including alcohol cannabis
cocaine and prescription drugs like
anti-y cartic and benzo dipine pending
additional investigation into the actors
in timely passing Perry's official cause
of death has been listed as deferred by
the Los Angeles County Medical Examiner
office which means additional tests will
be needed Perry was discovered when
Emergency Services were C his Los
Angeles home for a cardiac event while
Perry was in his hot tub
no illegal drugs were found at the scene
but police did find anti-depressants
anti-anxiety medication and COPD
medication though these were all
prescribed to Perry and stored properly
according to the Sun the actor best
known for his role as chanler Bing on
Friends was an outspoken advocate for
sobriety and addiction recovery and
wrote extensively about his addiction
issues in his 2022 Memoir friends lovers
and the big terrible thing he opens the
book by describing previous Health
scares including the time that his colon
burst due to complications from drug use
I'm a drug addict I'm a person that if I
have a drink I can't stop detailing the
tribulations he experienced after heavy
drug and alcohol use Perry wrote I am no
saint none of us are but once you have
been at death's door and you don't die
you would think you would be bathed in
relief and gratitude but that isn't it
at all instead you look at the difficult
road ahead of you to get better and you
are pissed something else happens too
you are plagued by this nagging question
why have I been spared unfortunately
Perry's passing likely could have been a
result of damage to his heart after
years of substance use WSLS ran Oak
spoke to cardiologist Dr Bradley Allen
who revealed that even people as young
as Perry could be susceptible to cardiac
events like heart attacks Dr Allan told
the news station we do see people in
their 40s and 50s fairly commonly having
heart attacks unfortunately the initial
presentation for a lot of folks is
sudden cardiac death which if that is
the case for Matthew Perry he's
unfortunately part of that statistic
another contributing factor could
possibly be Perry's use of his hot tub
particularly since he was alone
according to the clevand clinic hot
water can exacerbate pre-existing heart
conditions as ascribed to the clinic by
cardiologist Dr Curtis riman hot tubs
and saers are potentially dangerous for
patients with known or suspected heart
disease because a person's temperature
rises and blood pressure drops when one
uses a hot tub it can cause cardiac
events if a person is already suffering
from heart damage importantly if Perry
did experience a cardiac emergency it
likely would have been the result of his
past struggles with addiction and would
not indicate any recent substance use
particularly considering how well his
friends and family have reported him
doing in the past few years his pickle
ball coach told Entertainment Tonight he
was really focused on turning everything
around and he was doing a great great
job throughout his Too Short Life Perry
was a tireless advocate for anyone
suffering from addiction and he even
turned a home in Malibu into a sober
living house for a 2-year period Perry
worked with the National Association of
drug court professionals as a spokesman
and in 2013 President Barack Obama's
administration gave him a champion of
recovery award from the White House's
office of National Drug control policy
the best thing about me Barone is if
somebody comes up to me and says I can't
stop drinking can you help me
I can say yes if you or anyone you know
needs help with addiction issues help is
available visit the Substance Abuse and
Mental Health Services Administration
website or contact samsa's National
helpl line at 1800 662 help